Wubba lubba dub dub wisecrack Jared here
you've probably noticed that the
Internet has blown up talking about the
season 3 premiere of Rick and Morty the
Rick shank redemption but rather than
focusing on the fact that Justin roiland
and Dan Harmon pulled off quite possibly
the greatest anti April Fool's prank of
all time everyone can't stop talking
about that sweet Szechuan sauce and it's
delicious is the show doing something
more profound than just invoking a
totally random promotional condiment
from the clinton-era this sauce is
amazing absolutely and we're here to
break it down for you
welcome to his wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of Szechuan sauce we've
talked about the existential themes than
Rick and Morty before between Rick's
creations despairing over their
existence my purpose you pass butter oh
my god a persistent resentment towards
one's creators you brought me into this
world a suffering abomination and
Morty's unique life philosophy nobody
exists on purpose nobody belongs
anywhere everybody's gonna die they're
not exactly hiding it the show is also
dabbled in a sort of relative to
existentialism known as absurdism
according to French philosopher Albert
Camus we live a cruel and absurd
existence humans are cursed with seeking
meaning in a universe that will forever
remain silent and the image of a guy
pushing a boulder up a mountain for all
eternity is the perfect metaphor for the
human condition in the spirit of camu
Rick and Morty paints an absurd
meaningless multiverse Rick accordingly
has a long history of trivializing
everything nothing he doesn't believe in
things like love what people call love
is just a chemical reaction that compels
animals to breed or tradition well
scientifically traditions are an idiot
thing Rick's companionship with Morty is
allegedly only a means for Rick to hide
his genius brainwaves from the
government in the Rick shank redemption
we see similar themes the arbitrary
nature of our social systems wait who's
paying me to yell at this guy I can
answer that for money
mocking sentimentality we have infinite
grandkids you're trying to use Disney
bucks that have Caesars Palace here and
the pointlessness up at all oh when
you're not sure what you do for a living
you can make your own rules
that we live in a meaningless world is
an idea held by both absurdism and
existentialism but the transition from
the end of season 2 to the premiere of
season 3 really solidifies Rick and
Morty as an absurd work he's a spy blow
him up I'm gonna go take a [ __ ] it does
so by dangling meaning and hope in front
of us only to rip it to shreds something
notable happens at the end of season 2
Rick takes a break from his sociopathic
shenanigans to have an authentic
heartfelt moment that bird person's
wedding
birdperson is my best friend and if he
loves Tammy well then I loved Tammy -
[Applause]
but the show undercuts it when we
learned that Tammy is a spy what makes
this part special is that Rick's
flirtation with being a normal caring
person is undercut by an outside force
not his own cynicism this is further
explored at the end of the episode after
the family is forced into hiding from
the Galactic Federation Rick overhears
the hardships he's created for them in a
moment of seeming anguish Rick turns
himself over to the Federation I'm doing
what's right for the galaxy by calling
you so if we come back to earth can my
family have a normal life and will
likely spend the rest of his days in
prison in sacrificing himself the finale
suggests that Rick is wrestling with
something he's never dealt with living
with meaning given complete knowledge of
the meaninglessness of love life etc he
chose to do right by his family
regardless the cliffhanger teases a
possible shift in the show's existential
themes this idea of creating meaning in
a meaningless world is one championed by
many existentialist but firmly rejected
by Camus this crossroads for the show
parallels a beef camu had with a
particular thinker one who regularly
contributes to my existential angst
boners Fyodor Dostoyevsky
Kimmo writes that authors like dust is
key often propose absurd worlds with
characters who understand the frivolity
of life only to chicken out and retreat
to the comfort of meaning like religion
and [ __ ] the stoy ask these problem for
Camus is that he offers a reply to the
absurd some form of meaning whereas an
absurd work on the contrary does not
provide a reply existentialist like
jean-paul Sartre or destroy yes
he may realize the absurdity of
existence but their analysis fails by
resorting to hope or trying to create me
Camus said of them they defy what
crushes them and find reason to hope in
what impoverishes them at the end of
season 2 we may have thought the show
would make a similar retreat into
meaning and sentimentality but with the
release of the Rik shank redemption we
now know that this is not the case at
all
instead it doubles down on the absurd
not only was Rick's imprisonment a ploy
why would Rick Sanchez turn himself in
well I'm just a dumbass bug but it's
possible Rick knew he'd be interrogated
at this facility where we not only keep
our most wanted but our most sensitive
data but the show replies to our
prospect of a humanized Rick with a
journey that will be darker than ever oh
it gets darker Morty welcome to the
darkest year of our adventures and if
just a [ __ ] with us even more much of
Rick shanks comedy is not derived from
joking about life's meaninglessness like
in previous episodes but rather the
biggest jokes are largely derived from
our attempt to draw meaning where are we
going to the day it all began and ended
the moment that changed everything for
example when Rick explores the memory of
him creating the portal gun we learned
that Beth and Diane were brutally
murdered turning Rick from a family man
to a deranged loner scientist your
typical tragic Walter white style
antihero origin story that would give
meaning to his madness this Bates the
audience to empathize with Rick
but joke's on you it's all the rules
true but you can't alter anything you
want about a totally fabricated origin
story so it's not just that Rick and
Morty evades meaning the writer seemed
to get a perverse joy in playing with
our desire to search for hope and
meaning as if Camus was making his point
in the style of an internet troll
in another instance Rick saves Earth
from the brave new world inspired
Galactic Federation we may be tempted to
say that Rick did this for a greater
good
to liberate earth from their alien
oppressors however Summers comments
suggests that the new world order
doesn't sound too good either oh my god
Nancy says they're drawing and
quartering aliens in the school
courtyard and it technically counts as
patriotism in other moments the idea
that Rick cares about Morty and summer
is also toyed with we have your Morty at
summer first Rick seems to care as he
rushes to rescue Morty in summer after
they're imprisoned by the council of
ricks Rick van exhibits a casual
disregard for summers life and his
standoff with another Rick why not shoot
through the risk to me is minimized if I
wait for you to shoot her which I'm
encouraging you to do but we learned it
was all part of a well-crafted strategy
finally the whole Rick caring theory
disintegrates again as he explains he
only saved them so that Beth doesn't
kick him out of the house your mom
wouldn't have accepted me if I came home
without you and your sister so now you
know the real reason I rescued you which
finally brings us to the Szechuan sauce
Rick isn't motivated by family or
justice or love but only that Moulin
McNuggets sauce the show undercutting
even the most promising attempt to give
Rick a sense of morality doubles down by
suggesting his entire series arc will be
his quest for a forgotten promotional
food item that's what this is all about
Lori that's my one-armed man I'm not
driven by avenging my dead family Morty
that was fake I'm driven by fighting
that big nugget sauce I want that Moulin
McNuggets sauce Morty but this is really
what drives Rick no the only thing that
Rick's love of Szechuan sauce means is
that it means nothing
the quest for Szechuan sauce is in
creating meaning it's a reflection of
the absurdity of being driven by well
anything given the utter void of meaning
in the world why not dedicate yourself
to an absurd quest for plum flavored
McNugget sauce why not spend nine whole
seasons doing it if it takes nine
seasons
why not 97 years ninety seven more years
Morty the quest for McNugget sauce is
meaningful only in that it's a joke
about meaninglessness Kim who says that
any figure who understands and finds
happiness in the pointlessness of it all
is an absurd hero the absurd hero must
not only be happy with life's absurdity
but fully comprehend the cosmic
indifference that surrounds him he calls
it lucid indifference and this all seems
a lot like Rick and these babies just
save this lame-ass partay a man whose
knowledge of the vast multiverse were
everything terrible and good can and has
happened defines his existence what
about the reality where Hitler cured
cancer Morty a man who reduces our basic
morals to genetic programming a man who
in spite of being able to accomplish
anything
only yearns for Szechuan sauce there's
one important difference between cow
Moos absurd hero and Rick Sanchez absurd
heroes find happiness in the absurd but
as we know Rick is in great pain Morty
do you know what Wubba lubba dub dub
means in my peoples tongue it means I am
in great pain
maybe Rick's actual Ark will not be to
give more shits or to be nicer to his
family but to actually enjoy the
absurdity of it all so is the April
Fool's joke the fact that they actually
dropped the episode exactly when they
said they would turn into Rick and Morty
season 3 in like a year and a half or is
the real joke the prospect of Rick
finding meaning aka
this Szechuan sauce essentially if you
thought Rick's self-sacrifice was an
indication of a belief in Family Justice
or anything for that matter you've been
had there's just a lot more where that
came from to wobble of a dub dub
wisecrack and to check out our other
Rick and Morty videos click on any of
the links here peace
[Music]